we have seen examples in which the base
of the logarithm is 10 or sometimes it's
e log to the base e is also written as
Ln of the natural logarithm why is it
called the natural logarithm we will see
that in another video but for now you
should note that these two are the most
commonly used bases in logarithms base
10 and base E and most of the scientific
or the financial calculators have one or
both of these two logarithms so what
would we do if we are asked to find the
value of log eight to the base three
using a calculator we can't find this
value right that's where the change of
base formula comes into the picture the
change of base formula states that log
of a to the base B can be written as log
of a to the base x over log of B to the
base X log of a to any base x over log
of B to that same base X the bases in
the numerator and the denominator should
be the same of course the normal
conditions about the base and the
argument will still exist the base or in
this case X will be greater than zero
and X will not be equal to one and the
arguments a and B will be greater than
zero this is the change of base formula
quite easy to remember actually the
argument becomes the numerator the base
becomes the denominator and the bases
here will be the same and can be
anything coming back to our question how
do we find the value of log of 8 to the
base 3 because the calculator can't
really help us with this we can write it
as log of 8 to the base e over log of 3
to the base e the argument was written
in the numerator the base in the
denominator and the common base was
chosen as e the calculator can give us
these two values here's a scientific
calculator we can see that we are given
the natural log and the log to the base
10 buttons we are interested in the
natural log here the numerator is the
natural log
of eight the natural log of eight
approximately gives us 2.0 seven nine
four so we write two point zero seven
nine four in the numerator in the
denominator we have the natural log of
three that will approximately give us
1.0986 we write this in the denominator
and this value can be easily calculated
using the calculator two point zero
seven nine four over 1.0986
will give us one point eight nine to
wait approximately that's one of the
ways in which change of base helps us
some calculators also give us the value
of log to the base 10 so this can also
be written as log of eight to the base
ten over log of three to the base ten
let's see what this gives us log to the
base 10 can also be written as log log
implies log to the base 10 log of eight
gives us this approximately zero point
nine zero three one now we move on to
the denominator log of three will give
us this zero point four seven seven one
what do you think this value should be
equal to zero point nine zero three one
divided by zero point four seven seven
one gives us this one point eight nine
to eight approximately it's the same
value and it has to be the same value
the log of a to the base three has just
one value and it's this doesn't matter
how we calculate it that was the change
of base formula and with this formula
there's one other minor property we can
derive we know this formula now if we
divide the numerator and the denominator
by log of a to the base X we get this
look at the denominator now what will
this be equal to using the change of
base formula again it will equal log of
B to the base a it will equal this we
get log of a to the base be equal to one
over log B to the base a and multiplying
both sides with log of B to the base a
will result in this
of a to the base be multiplied by log of
B to the base a will equal one
you